There's also been a lot of scrutiny lately about the culture in Silicon Valley,...
...the treatment of women in Silicon Valley and some of the other big tech companies.
As a leader, you look at that and say what?
What needs to change?
Wow!
I think it's really important to continue to encourage women...
...to be a part of the tech community.
When there are more women in the tech community,...
...I think things will most definitely change.
I think being part of Facebook, Instagram has been an incredible experience.
Sheryl Sandberg is leading the company...
...and internally, we have lots of conversations about unconscious bias.
I think that we have a lot of work to do...
...and this is something that we're most definitely focused on...
...and I am focused on it in Instagram.